wake up java the bell don't sweat now
feeling swell and you got it's a
beautiful day you're gonna burn my truck
I'm going
I'm the wall
Oh
valentine's Day is closing in on us
friends there's not much time left
before the traditional rush to panic by
whatever heart-shaped gift you can find
in the supermarket so you can remind
your loved ones that consumerism is the
only way to prove how you feel it's also
one of those holidays that people get
all cynical about but even if you're
alone on this heartwarming day of
commercialized romance you can still
join in with one of its traditional
activities swooning over hot people
there and so we bring you our carefully
curated list of all the people we fancy
in fallout 4 twist they're the cutest
unruh man ssible characters because we
like our love unrequited warning this
episode contains spoilers for side
quests and companions to view at your
peril who I do love a man in power and
he's got that kind of rugged bear grylls
thing going for him I bet he smells like
firewood and chest hair he does have an
excellent beard which is often a sign of
high testosterone so you know he'd make
a good baby daddy Plus doubt lineage
sure synth curie is an s-rank cutie but
don't dismiss ball curie so quickly that
girl / robot is nothing but curves and
she's super smart too as much as we'd
like to take her hand on a walk on the
beach kiri has a buzz saw blowtorch
three hours and probably some kind of
storage in that big body of hers and
since we've already seen the human robot
romance barriers being torn down in
diamond city it's probably not such a
taboo but who doesn't like a bit of
mystery lovely Deacon has you covered
with his ever-changing looks as
ever-present sunglasses and his
enigmatic way of never telling you the
truth yup deacons a big fat liar so you
never know just how many of his tall
tales are factual and as it turns out
he's been following you since you left
the vault because he loves you maybe
it's better cop out to say someone
wearing gigantic hydraulic armor is
strong in Proctor Ingram's case it's
definitely true after losing both her
legs in battle she continued working for
the Brotherhood of Steel as their lead
engineer using a modified power armor
suit to retain her mobility she's an
engineering wizard a badass and
according to one fellow brotherhood
member she loves sweets
in a world filled with humans robots and
many people who are both surely there's
nothing wrong with a little bit of bot
love if you're going to go there you
might as well go all the way with this
hunk of junk you know when they say
there's more to love well there's a lot
to love of Captain Ironsides just make
sure you get your smooches in while you
can if Captain Ironsides doesn't tickle
your pickle how about Cleo the
wastelands friendliest a soldier on
there's something alluring about that
gal that can kill you with a look
literally she's an enterprising last
running a weapon stalling good neighbor
and if you hack a terminal you find that
all sorts of juicy secrets mostly about
how she plans to kill everyone never
look at a girl's diary everyone loves a
bad boy Jack Cabot isn't the leather
jackets and motorbikes kind of bad guy
but he's definitely a corrupt scientist
and he has daddy issues too but maybe
you can fix him it's basically the plot
of a really terrible rom-com but with
the added twist that he has what
basically amounts to the elixir of life
so you can live happily ever after
forever so whether you've got someone in
your life or you're planning to spend
Valentine's Day with your one true love
pizza we hope you can appreciate the
fallout has some damn fine young men and
women to love hopefully we'll be able to
afford virtual reality soon so we can
actually spend Valentine's Day with some
sexy mpcs instead of having to awkwardly
explain why you forgot to buy flowers as
always don't forget to send in your
creations with the hashtag GS fall out
and let us know in the comments who
you'd Wuan fall out if you only have the
chance
Oh